sur le coup je me suis ça peut te rien
et je me suis pas rendu compte que plus
que normal banal
puis le 13 septembre deux semaines après
je suis heureuse j'ai complètement de
paralyser la jambe droite complètement
d'une femme qui a contracté le virus du
nil
le québec a connu un nombre record de
cas d'infection au virus du nil l'année
passion 2018 selon les dernières données
du ministère de la santé
donc c'est une infection qui est
transmise à l'humain par la piqûre de
moustiques et les moustiques sont
porteurs le virus a été contracté par
201 québécois en 2018 15 personnes en
sont décédées c'est vraiment jamais vu
au québec on en parle avec jacques
boisvert un microbiologiste à la
retraite de l'université du québec à
trois rivières ce bois vert bonjour
bonjour bon parlons à de cette hausse
fulgurante en 2018 quand on compare à
2017 où il y avait eu 27 personnes qui
avaient été touchés par le virus du nil
comme on explique qu'une explosion de
cas comme ça on n'est pas capable de
l'expliquer ya peu on on a besoin de
beaucoup plus de données il a
présentement tout ce qu'on a aussi la
température
aperture et qui nous permet d'avoir un
biais de grisou qui est un outil utilisé
par les cultivateurs et l'autre celle
indices sectoriels
le problème avec 6,1 dit cela c'est
souvent trop fait même depuis 2003 qu on
en utilise quelques-uns depuis 2003 on
n'est pas grave à faire la corrélation
de ces grosses indirects uriel avec
beaucoup de coups comme en 2018 avec les
deux sens encore les districts auriel ça
a été un des plus beaux dans les cinq
dernières années
donc c'est inexplicable selon les
données que vous avez à vous demander
est ce qu'il ya de plus en plus d'un
moustique qui sont porteurs où il ya de
plus en plus de moustiques tout court la
quantité de moustiques sont pas
nécessairement des qui aura plus de
conduit 2 une île parce que vous publiez
c'est une infection chez les oiseaux il
faudrait surveiller des oiseaux etc sont
infectés ou pas infecté si vous
beaucoup de moustiques beaucoup beaucoup
de moustier comment semble-t-il renault
cette année mais les oiseaux sont pas
infectés safra programme du tunnel que
la cohue humaine et l'autre chose qui
remportait aussi à signaler c'est que
par exemple en californie
on utilise six critères différents avant
d'être terminée si on fait des
traitements au québec et en ontario
c'est complètement différent vu qu'on
fait des traitements préventifs avec un
insecticide biologique dans les pays
américains de the roots et lorsqu'on
atteint un certain seuil ou les
moustiques sont dangereux des pouilles
infectés mais infectieux ils sont alors
on sent les avions pour la route ou à
cesser
qu'est-ce qu'on va le faire au québec
ont décidé d'utiliser certains des
critères du cdc d'attenté center for
disease control infections alors que
c'est fait pour les états qui utilisent
des adultes side
il faudra voir cela de haut à z tout ce
qu'on fait en fer en faire on fait des
captures de moustiques ont fait des
tests semaine le test ont fait une fois
ces moustiques et dangereux il nous dit
si possiblement il pourrait devenir
dangereux
oui c'était forcément saint jude et
américaines
on sait que c'est pour toujours une
bonne idée mais peut-être développer nos
propres critères avec des gens dont
taille où il ya des gens ici qui sort là
que poussière net alioune kassé de
développer des modèles de prédiction se
passe quand vous avez parlé au début
vous avez dit cette année on a vraiment
beaucoup à des moustiques donc en
général on ne sait pas quel est le
pourcentage qui sont pourtant bien sûr
du virus mais dites-nous deux choses
quelles sont les principaux symptômes du
virus du nil et comment se protéger pour
ne pas être affecté les principes aux
est une chose bien important quand vous
parlez de 202 une chose pour que les
gens sachent c'est une maladie bénigne
mais soixante dix pour cent des 201
record c'était des gens qui ont fait une
encéphalite une infection du cerveau x
se sont amorcées aux soins intensifs
ça c'est pour vous
ce qui est assez parlante semaine les
personnes qui veut ça et comme la madame
disais au début de notre émission là il
ya des séquelles énorme à sévir à la
fois la rend juste comme une petite
maladie bénigne mais pour la bavière
la grosse majorité j'en ai pas de
symptômes 80% il ya pas de symptômes
9 1 % 19 qui doit rester c'est une bonne
ou bonne grippe qui vont s'absenter du
travail carmen pendant quelques jours
mais c'est le 1% à moi qui m'inquiète
personnellement d'encéphalite du cerveau
la fois ces cas mais il faut faire
attention à cela
des études qui ont été faites aux états
unis qui montrent des séquelles jusqu'à
5 6 1 appelée et comme pour ne pas être
infecté
ben c'est toujours les classes et qu'on
n'en parle de plus en plus les vêtements
de couleur parle des vêtements alors
évidemment de couleur parle parce que
les moustiques sont insérées par les
couleurs chaudes
le bleu marine le noir le rouge foncé
toutes ces couleurs foncées de ses
satires comparé des vêtements de couleur
par on avait trouvé un autre au cours de
nos anita vous réserve faunique
symbolisme que le jaune le jaune canari
c'est un très bonne couleur caisse des
dépôts les limousines mais bonjour bas
les gens de montréal prenait un jaune
canari hollande mais et puis des
répulsifs
il y en a beaucoup il ya un nouveau le
kit à base de ica lydienne qu'on
commence à retrouver un peu partout à
les grandes surfaces et c'est un p tit
re un chasse moustiques ont dit mais qui
est aussi efficace que le dit les parcs
ont contrairement ou dit qu'ils étaient
seulement un plastique lui fera position
des plastiques très bien bien on prend
ça on note merci pour vos conseils et
également s est
ces termes que vous souvenez vous dit
qu'on doit changer nos façons de faire
okc au canada revoir pour mieux
mieux faire en sorte de prévenir
finalement le virus n'est mieux
intervenir également merci beaucoup
monsieur boisvert d'avoir été là ce
matin pour lui dire au revoir